if you have a condition in your neck
that puts pressure on your spinal cord
or spinal nerves your doctor may
recommend a cervical disc replacement
the spine in your neck also called the
cervical spine has 7 Bones called
vertebrae
the front part of each vertebra is
called the vertebral body except for the
first vertebra
between most vertebrae is a soft cushion
of cartilage called an intervertebral
disc
the back part of each vertebra has a
curved section called the vertebral arch
except for the first vertebra each
vertebral arch has a bony projection
called the spinous process
on each side of the spinous process is a
flat piece of bone called a lamina the
vertebral arch of the vertebra surrounds
and protects your spinal cord
a column of nervous tissue connecting
your brain to other nerves in your body
your spinal cord passes through an
enclosed space called the vertebral
canal which is formed by the vertebral
arches of your vertebrae
over time your cervical spine may
develop problems such as a shrinking
disk
a herniated or
to disk
or bony growths on your vertebrae called
bone spurs
these changes can narrow your vertebral
canal and put pressure on your spinal
cord or the nerves that branch off of it
the pressure can cause neck pain and
stiffness or pain numbness and weakness
in your arms or hands
before your procedure an intravenous
line or IV will be started you may be
given antibiotics through the IV to
decrease your chance of infection you
will be given general anesthesia to make
you unconscious and pain-free during the
procedure a breathing tube will be
inserted through your mouth and down
your throat to help you breathe during
the operation
your surgeon will make an incision on
your neck the part of your cervical
spine containing the damaged disc will
be exposed your surgeon will remove the
entire damaged disc then your surgeon
will remove any bone spurs
the vertebral bodies above and below the
removed discs will be trimmed to allow
placement of an artificial disc
finally your surgeon will insert the
artificial disc which may be held in
place with screws
the artificial disc is designed to
preserve normal motion at this level of
your spine
your skin incision may be closed with
skin glue or skin closure tape
after your procedure your breathing tube
will be removed and you will be taken to
the recovery area for monitoring you'll
be given pain medication as needed you
may be released from the hospital within
1 to 2 days after your procedure